We are on problem 63.
The height of a triangle
is 4 inches greater
than twice its base.
Let me this triangle
in question.
That's the triangle, that's its
height, that's its base.
Let's say this is the base.
Let's call that b.
So then the height, that's that,
is 4 inches greater than
twice its base.
So 4 inches more than
2 times the base.
Fair enough.
The area of the triangle
is 168 square inches.
What is the base of
the triangle?
So what's the area
of a triangle?
It's the base times the
height times 1/2.
So area is equal to 1/2
base times height.
Well they told us that the
height is four more than twice
the base, so we can just
substitute that in.
And then we'll have a just
in terms of the base.
Let me keep that there.
So the area is equal to 1/2
the base times the height,
which they told us is 4 more
than twice the base.
And now if we distribute
the 1/2 b.
1/2 b times 4 is equal to 2b.
And then 1/2 b times 2b,
that's plus b squared.
1/2 time 2 is 1 and then
b times b is b squared.
Fair enough.
And they tell us that
the area is 168.
OK, so we have area is 168, and
that's equal to 2 times
the base plus the
base sqaured.
Let's swap the sides just
to make it look
a little bit familiar.
B squared plus 2 times the
base is equal to 168.
We could subtract 168
from both sides.
You get b squared plus 2b
minus 168 is equal to 0.
And 168 is a bit of
a strange number.
I don't know exactly which
numbers go into 168.
Let's see, 4 isn't
going to work.
Does 12 go into it?
Yeah, 12 goes into 168,
and I think it
goes into it 14 times.
So that works.
So you could use the quadratic
equation to solve this.
But I think that 12
times 14 is 168.
And they have to be of different
signs, since this is
a negative.
Only different signs
when multiplied get
you a negative number.
And they're 2 apart.
So that works out.
So you get b plus 14 times
b minus 12 is equal to 0.
Let me just confirm and
not waste your time.
14 times 12, I'm pretty
sure I'm right.
Yeah, 168.
I just factored that out.
So b could be equal
to minus 14.
Right, that would make that 0.
Or b could be equal to 12,
which would make that 0.
Obviously if you can make one
of these terms 0, you're
making this whole thing 0.
And the base, since we're
dealing with distances or
lengths, we can't have
a negative length.
So the base has to
be 12 inches.
Which is choice C in
that question.
Next question.
Problem 64.
All right.
This is a good one.
What is that thing reduced
to lowest terms?
So essentially what they want
us to do is factor stuff out
and factor it out and write it
as a product of factors and
then cancel out the ones.
So let's see what we can do.
Can we factor that
top expression?
Let's see.
This is looks like a perfect
square, right?
Because if you have minus 2y
squared is 4y squared.
And minus 2y and minus
2y is minus 4y.
So the top expression is
x minus 2y squared.
And I'll just write it twice.
Because I'm guessing that one
of them are going to have to
be factored out.
And once, the intuition is that
if I had this, x squared
minus 4x plus 4, you say OK,
what two numbers when you
multiply them equal four
and when you add
them equal minus 4?
You say, minus 2 and you'd so
that's equal to x minus
2 and x minus 2.
The only difference between
that and that is
they put y's here.
Y and a y squared.
OK, so you could visualize this
thing as x squared minus
4yx plus 4y squared.
Or you could visualize this as x
squared minus two times 2y x
plus 2y squared.
This isn't 4y squared.
This is 4 y squared.
Forget the parentheses.
But I hope you can see that this
thing up here is the same
thing is this thing
right here.
And that's where I got the
intuition that that's going to
be x minus 2y times
x minus 2y.
You say, OK what two numbers
when you add
them are 2 times 2y?
Well, obviously 2y.
And what numbers when you
squared them are 2y squared?
Well 2y times 2y
is 2y squared.
So that's where you get the
intuition that it's x minus 2y
times x minus 2y.
That's the numerator, let's see
what we can do with the
denominator.
Well immediately, both factors
are divisible by 3 and both
terms are divisible by y.
So let's factor those out.
So this is equal to 3y.
Now if you divide this term
by 3y, all you're
left with is an x.
3xy divided by 3y, you
just have an x.
And then if you divide minus
6y squared by 3y, minus six
divided by 3 is minus 2, y
squared divided by y is y.
Let's see, if we assume that x
does not equal 2y, because
then this would be undefined,
we can cancel these two out.
And you're just left with
x minus 2y over 3y.
And that is choice B.
Problem 65.
They want us to do it again.
OK, let's see.
So this top expression,
everything is divisible by 3,
so let's rewrite it.
Let's factor out a 3 there.
So it'd be 3 times to 2x
squared, plus 7x-- or 21
divided by 3-- Plus 3.
Let's see, what's
the bottom one?
Well this fits a pattern.
A squared minus b
squared, right?
This is something squared.
4x squared is 2x squared.
And then 1 is obviously
1 squared.
So we can write this as a
plus b times a minus b.
And that would be 2x plus
1, times 2x minus 1.
2x squared is 4x squared,
and 1 squared is 1.
So let's see, we factored
that top part.
And I'm guessing it's going to
cancel out with something in
the denominator.
So let's see what we can get.
Let me do it on the side here.
So if I have to factor 2x
squared plus 7x plus 3, it's
going to be 2x plus something
times x plus something.
Because 2x times the
x is 2x squared.
And the b times the a is
going to be equal to 3.
So I'm guessing one of them is
going to be a 3 and one of
them is going to be 1.
And I could already guess, if
we could do it a little bit
more systematically than
how it's going, so
let's multiply it out.
2x times x, 2x squared.
2x times a, plus 2ax.
B times x, plus bx.
B times a, plus ba.
So you get 2x squared, then
merge these terms, add the
coefficients.
Plus 2a plus bx, that's those
two terms. Plus ba is equal to
this thing up here.
I'll write it right below it so
we can compare terms. It's
equal to 2x squared
plus 7x plus 3.
So what could a and b equal?
Let's see, 2 times a plus b is
equal to-- so if a is 3 and
this is 1, 2 times 3 is
6 plus 1 is 7, works.
And then 3 times 1 is 7.
So b is 1 and a is 3.
And you could multiply that
out if you're not
comfortable with it.
But anyway, we could rewrite
this top thing as 3 times--
and we did the factoring here,
we figured out that b and a
are 2x plus 1, times x plus 3.
All of that over 2x plus
1, times 2x minus 1.
And we know we're on the right
track because we've got
something to cancel out.
And sure enough, we
cancel those out.
Assuming that this
never equals 0.
This x does not equal minus 1/2,
because that would make
that equal 0.
And we get 3 times x plus
3 over 2x minus 1.
And that is choice B.
Let me see the next problem,
see if we have time
to do it right now.
Oh, it's another one of these.
I'll wait for the next
video, see you soon.